pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing company
dedicated to making the very best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built-a-wear
not to wear out visit grip6.compogchamps
i get to meet rain he's amazing
dude do you want to play like irl
yeah and make out too come on now come
in this match i'm not really
sure what to expect um
but i do expect the games to be pretty close
look good i just got a shot into bobby hall's
outfit he's just like oh wow it's isn't that
looks like something right out of the 1970s
but he's dressed like dwight from the office
true that's true i literally literally
last night and said wait till you see my outfit
but i had no idea this was what he was going
to do this is hilarious oh my god yeah all right
well here you go everybody we've got rayne wilson
versus dwight schrute and this is going to be this
is going to be epics dwight you're dwight schrute
against logic do i shoot against logic is what
it should be yep um you just said rayne wilson
against dwight shirt well because he just said you
know ray wilson's playing playing dwight schrute
here oh sorry oh you're riffing off that sorry
okay okay yeah yeah anyway that's hilarious and uh
we'll see we'll see if rayne notices it in the
post-match interviews regardless of what happens
but okay exactly yeah apparently he actually is
streaming without a mic i've just been so okay
oh so he'll be quiet okay so okay so he's just
gonna be quiet for the whole time basically well
he played d6 and reign quickly played one um yeah
pretty standard so far i would say nothing really
out of the ordinary yeah the biggest thing right
now this is gonna be such a close positional game
the clock starts to hurt you if you're rooting for
logic because he's already down two minutes and
i'm struggling to find a plan here because like
you said d5 is the logical thing to do but it's
hard to make yourself play it that's true yeah i
mean i i don't know i don't know what else you do
you can play rookie d5 you may move the knight and
then play f5 or try to but very very difficult oh
wow look at that he finds it well he does it very
nice but again i don't think there's any anything
is guaranteed actually he takes on f3 which is not
bad but i think he has to follow it up with some
some critical moves which won't be easy like
knight h5 maybe or 97 knight she says knight f4
that h4 is not a bad idea he's trying to attack
but it can also get you in big trouble here
but then i don't know a knight on the rim as we
say a knight on the rim is dim or grim um and the
knight on the rim is not really doing anything
here cause it can't go back to f5 because the
bishop covers the f5 square but it also can't go
to f3 so your knight is kind of out to lunch and
you can't bring it back to the center of the board
uh very easily but look at this f5 i like it from
from bobby's perspective he's trying to justify
where all of his pieces are placed right now right
he's looking for f4 and e4 do something right with
all of the all the king side pieces that he has i
like what i'm seeing here i felt that maybe in
the first match he's a little bit more on edge
um but he seems like he's he's been preparing
studying and i think he's doing doing really
well once again brain's trying to get rid of the
pawn on f5 that would be probably a good trade for
him oh h5 oh but it doesn't work here because the
king comes up but no you still get mated because
right you get rook g2 and then king h g6 is
still checking oh he wanders at h4 logic's
gonna see the checkmate i think he's got mate
and two yeah now king g4 and rook g2 is checkmate
i think logic should see rook g2 and then
because he creates a new picture as xqc said
then he should see g6 unbelievable logic again
loki has been a guy who's been crushing and
working on his chess i mean he's got lessons
he takes regularly and he he's been playing
this is a guy that might be surprising people
as as a potential favorite oh my god look at him
clean that up what a game from black so beautiful
okay the next game begins so not too much time to
talk about it we've got e4 on the board rain
playing his his pierce that he played but one
tip i gave him after playing the losing tactic
against tubbo that he got away with with bishop g4
i said don't play bishop g4 right rain don't play
bishop g4 here oh oh i'm sure he won't right okay
we went over it that was after he played on day
two that was the only thing we went over i said
and i still don't play you got away with murder
there um okay he didn't play it good call
i'm actually very concerned for rayne wilson i
found it whoa he played it wow did he really just
see that pawns not under attack i find it hard
to believe that he might have gotten or yeah i
think he got lucky kind of like xqc got lucky
against daniel leguano like xqc did not see the
idea with bishop takes b5 in the discover check
um but then once he got there he figured it out
i feel like rayne probably didn't even realize his
pawn is oh and oh and logic takes it oh no oh man
well i think rain is going to win this game
we're headed to our our our megadon which is
funny i think rain rain will be the only player
who's played two armageddon matches for sure
the one he had with michelle care is that
is that still the only armageddon we've had
or have we had others i think that's the only
only one we've had wow okay so probably just
rookie 8 here and i think yeah i think
this one's going to be over pretty soon
save the rook give a check but yeah this should
be straightforward now and and yeah i think we're
arma armor get it on doesn't armageddon
oh there's no it's our megadon or megadon
armageddon i mean a logic can play
h5 to stop it but it's it's not
it's not really going to change
anything in the situation
yeah f5 was good he gets his king out but like
you said couldn't change it and sort of uh yeah
just bishop takes h4 and uh and yeah rain's gonna
win this game we're gonna have have another one
by the way however with this being a um what was
that right i was gonna say what is what is rook f3
okay yeah okay now he has queen
e4 to uh to finish off the game
24 is a good stylistic move just
just pick up the pick up a pony
fun fact chess was invented at the shoot
farms uh that was a great line for us
yeah greeted me diamond membership that was
hilarious um all right queen e4 come on rain
there you go any fines now not the blunder
king h3 queen f4 that's the only thing
that would be stalemate yes and less than ideal
still based steven right yep so i think the idea
is yeah you i think for rain though it's pretty
easy you take with the rook and then you just
do the ladder with queenie three work up two
queen f1 well remember bobby's already been
still mated once in the event right yeah so it's
true he really should have played king h3 there
i think i think that um yeah that would have been
his chance that was a good call he didn't see it
and now rain will play rook h2 or queen
f3 rook f3 some combination of the win
waiting exactly yeah holding old yep holding
yeah we're still waiting what's he doing holding
okay he's doing the other one he's doing the
reverse ladder he's just doing queen e3 and
rook four so we will actually have armageddon
done in the final game in the final match all
right sorry we have one more match don't worry we
got hbc pokey after this too for sure right right
right exactly so oh man yeah so we get our our
our arm armageddon i screwed you up armageddon
yeah exactly yeah all right all right everyone
don't go anywhere hey carl and i be back with
megatron and the whole crew is coming back we got
bumblebee we got shyla buff it's arma get it on
pog champ's style and okay here we go final
game five minutes to four minutes or mega dome
okay pretty standard so far let's see
what's gonna happen it should be five
probably bishop c5 i assume okay also it's gonna
say the logic has been pretty slow yeah that
that's a good point and maybe that's part of why
rayne chose yeah chose white to take advantage of
the clock true this is the armageddon game
so white has to win here rain has to win
bobby wins on both a draw and a loss
oh wow look at these pawns here i mean
yeah he's trying to create the wall here on on
the fourth rank uh he's already got three of them
at some point you can maybe push
d4 and gotta get a get a big wall
so um really really good position for rayne
wilson here but it's funny because it's one
that could backfire right because obviously it's
very good especially if you know someone like you
is playing but it's one of those positions where
if he doesn't convert on it his king is going to
be wide open and that could lead to a draw right
exactly yeah very true so after g5 probably 97
i mean maybe rook the eighth here um knight a3 is
a really good move though by um by rayne wilson to
go knight c4 yeah he needed to get developed and
and coming to c4 i can't highlight apparently um
yeah that's his place and now
just like queen of three and
rook d1 just sits on the the great wall of peshka
not the great wall of china anyway so the great
wall of peshka okay now he's gonna have f5
here yeah if i was just winning here
for white i think um anyway good
yeah yeah oh we played it you played
at five yeah he's crushing it here
yeah rain is just crushing it in this
game he's playing really really well
very very smooth game from from
rain you can bring the queen out
bring the queen out you can also maybe just
move his king over okay knight c6 i like but
at the same time yeah i i don't know there's
27 no i'm with you yeah he goes back to e5
so now he's probably just mopping it up but
you're right though because the risk if he
loses his focus somehow let's not forget all
this queen needs is a queen g5 or a queen g3
and and a draw remember wins the game for bobby so
rain has to be careful i i would love to have seen
him play like queen of three and rook d1 it's not
over as long as bobby has a chance for some checks
right exactly yeah yeah this is uh but overall
very very good game from rain i mean i think
certainly we've been talking up like one of the
favorites but the way that he's playing um the way
he's playing this game has been incredible and now
just he just does not take on g6 that would be a
i mean it's still winning but that would be start
to create problems because right now he's no
no shelter around his king he's got a bunch
of pawns that are being pushed up the board
yeah queen out oh okay finally he does it queen
f3 is a really good sign you can put the king on
h1 or h2 as said and then maybe use the
g file for his rook yeah this is i mean
really really good for uh for rain he's playing
this is just a model game from rain model game
okay very very very good luck's getting closer
together i don't even know what to say it's
just breaking although what's the time the time is
getting close let's look at the time it's only 20
seconds for rain and remember there's no increment
in this one guys that's it's no longer ten plus
five this is the time you see is the time they get
no help cut right it's straight up you just you
straight up no increment i mean if rain gets down
on the clock i'm not sure he's gonna win this yeah
we're down to what one minute about both players
getting i mean rain is about to be down on the
clock he's it's very close he allowed that check i
don't know and that's a check that's a check uh-oh
okay oh 94 oh my gosh this is getting wild gosh oh
bobby had 94. you missed it but he's got to keep
going there's just no panic just keep going oh no
yeah and now he sees now he plays chess too late
we have six queen of six queen f6 we have six and
remember bobby wins on a draw as long as brain's
king is open this is not over yeah bobby just
has to move you're just moving you hope you just
he's going full kambakaze yeah
that was not his most logical move
right there's one last hope if if knight f7 though
wait knight f7 is a fork right oh owie 97 is game
over yeah or rook g1 as long as he doesn't
allow queen g2 here oh wow he finds work g1
beautiful move by rayne very well played i think i
think you're right i think he's
going to get it now for sure
wow yeah and also yeah i mean bobby just kind of
he kind of collapsed under pressure when they both
had no time um but again it's an armageddon
game so any anything goes kind of in a way
although could there be a stalemate there's
probably not because there's a still yeah
but based on where the pawns are there's no style
mate too many pawns that can be pushed four pawns
and also you saw that uh logic just he started
clapping so uh he's basically conceded defeat here
yep all out of check as long as
reign checks there he goes yeah
right we're going to have interviews
with both these guys can't wait to talk
to uh logic about his outfit with rayne wilson
um identity theft is a crime bobby what do you
have to say about your outfit yeah it i
i like my outfit i thought it would be
kind of funny and i hope it wouldn't be taken
the wrong way i thought he'd get the joke and
yeah it's awesome i think you look incredibly
handsome rayne do you want to say anything
about the terrible coach you have or anything
do you want to get that off your chest or or no
you're the worst i am the worst you're the worst
okay you've known bobby for years you didn't even
prepare me for him and um you always talk about
like this idea of outpost nights which i'm kind
of just starting to learn about but his night
being there just screwed me yeah i was just
destroyed once he got his night there
i was just when i say i was [ __ ]
i just couldn't do anything and my and my
my rook all the way on the other side was
not helping me and and then i didn't see this
little ploy you know with him taking my bishop
there and i just i got screwed and he just it was
a masterful game man he just like it was like the
vice just turning and i couldn't get out of it
thank you it was cool and like i said this is my
first time like ever competing in anything so
this is just giving me what about rap battles
i guess so are you telling me you never saw
eight mile i i was low-key that guy in real life
but yes i did rap battle but it was mainly in
high school and then i was like [ __ ] this i
want to like make actual music and that was fun
and now i'm here getting my ass kicked by rain but
i just wanted to say that even though you know i
lost this um it was it's a really great experience
and it's gotten me even more excited about chess
and this whole competition has made me want to
i mean every day i'm playing every day i'm doing
puzzles every day i'm playing my rating is going
up and that's exciting so the fact that we get to
do all this and it's for charity and like i get
to meet rain is amazing dude do you want to play
like irl yeah and make out too come on now come on
uh yeah no that would be just to go too far
well regardless of the result guys you actually
tied for first in your group so you're both
going to the championship bracket you finish
with seven points a piece um and um i don't
get any are we going to meet again i hope i
don't have to play him again it's possible you
can meet the final you won't meet in the first
round but it's possible you could meet in the
finals so this could be uh could be a preview
heck yeah heck yeah baby heck yeah baby um irl
chess soon you were a worthy opponent man and you
play great chess and thank you um you were a wily
adversary and um took every every pubic hair i had
any dresses will too sure yes i do i i think i
have the swag it's a long-sleeve mustard shirt
it is what do you think what are you
doing you need the short sleeve bro
all right maybe i should maybe i should have
done that but yeah thank you as well um that
was the craziest game of chess i'd ever played
that first one i mean this whole the whole match
um it was exciting i was nervous you know my heart
was pounding like but yeah because i just really
care about chess and i really respect you not only
in your profession but as a player watching these
games that you've been playing so thank you so
much for uh an amazing oh you're very you're
very kind i respect you as well and i hope we
i hope we meet in the finals man that will be
that will be the battle of the century that'd
be sick but you guys are both awesome seriously
you gave us you gave us the match of the day
so far heading to armageddon we wish you guys
the best of luck in the championship bracket and
uh we'll we'll see you then awesome thank you guys
you